[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
welt heute bekommt er ein weiteres
plätzchen rezept und zwar das linzer
plätzchen rezept und die zutaten dazu
stelle ich euch jetzt vor
für den teig braucht ihr 250 gramm
butter 100 g puderzucker 300 gramm mehl
200 gramm gemahlene haselnüsse vier
teelöffel zimt und zwei messer spitzen
elke zwei esslöffel cacau
das sind etwa 30 gramm und einem eigelb
die zutaten die sollten alle
zimmertemperatur haben und jetzt wird
daraus ein rap tag hergestellt den könnt
ihr entweder mit den händen kneten oder
ihn benutzt eure handwerk gerät und zwar
die knethaken oder einem die
küchenmaschine und ich werde das jetzt
heute im thermomix machen
für die zubereitung im thermomix nehmt
ihr einfach den deckel ab und gibt alle
zutaten nacheinander ein
[Musik]
und dann sollten etwa 40 sekunden auf
stufe vier reichen
und so sieht dann der fertige teig aus
den fertigen teig in eine schüssel oder
in klarsichtfolie und gebt ihn für etwa
drei stunden in den kühlschrank
der teig für die linzer plätzchen ist
schön kalt und nass zu kalt ist müsst
ihr in ganz kurz geschmeidig kneten und
ich halt mit den ist einfach und rolle
denn zwischen zwei folien aus da brauche
ich nehm dich eigentlich nur ganz wenig
mehr
[Applaus]
und alles aus von hilfe nämlich mehr
wieder zwei essstäbchen und geht dies
sozusagen als abstandshalter mit dazu
damit der teig nicht dünner wird als ich
möchte
dann entfernte ich die essstäbchen und
strait den teig einmal um von ihm von
der folie zu lösen
als ausstich förmchen nehme ich mir
diese drei also das herz den ställen und
den tannenbaum und dann lege ich mir
auch schon meine back folie zu recht auf
die ich später die plätzchen legen werde
und dann stelle ich mir jetzt zuerst
einmal herzchen aus
[Musik]
ihr müsst ihr plätzchen frauen die man
doppelt ausstechen den nach dem backen
werden immer zwei hälften
zusammengeklebt
[Musik]
die eine hälfte kommt jetzt auf ein
backpapier und die andere auf ein
anderes denn eine hälfte wird nämlich
löcher bekommen und ihr müsst ihr auf
zwei unterschiedlichen backbleche backen
weil sie unterschiedliche garzeiten dann
haben
die löcher mache ich jetzt mit zu einer
loch thüle meines spritzbeutel ihr könnt
aber auch kleinere plätzchen ausstechen
nehmen und da habt ihr eigentlich ganz
viele möglichkeiten beim weihnachtsbaum
dem tannenbaum mache ich jetzt hier zwei
löcher oder man es klappt sogar trainer
herausnehmen nehme ich mir hier ist eine
pinzette
[Musik]
und so sieht es dann aus wenn die
plätzchen fertig auf den blechen
verteilt sind
also hier auf dem blech habe ich nur die
mit löchern und auf dem habe ich nur die
ohne löcher eben in der backzeit und aus
den resten habe ich hier noch so kleine
tannenbaum ausgestopften lege ich jetzt
hier mit drauf mal die dieses gleich
wieder kürzer packten die plätzchen
werden dann bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
gebacken und das blech mit den löchrigen
plätzchen hat bei mir etwa acht minuten
gebraucht und die plätzchen ohne löcher
haben einfach zehn minuten gebraucht
ihr müsst darauf achten dass sie auf
keinen fall dunkel werden also lieber
etwas zu früh als zu spät raus nehmen
denn im plätzchen werden sie uns etwas
bitter und nach dem backen könnte ich
sie dann auskühlen lassen und danach
werden sie gewöhnt und zusammengesetzt
bevor ich die plätzchen netz fülle
beschreibe ich die deckel mit
puderzucker damit später die marmelade
schön ohne butter zucker bleibt
[Musik]
wie lege ich dann kurz zur seite und
nehme mir etwas flacher pflaumenmus muss
jetzt erst einmal erhitzt werden
dazu gebe ich sie in einen kleinen topf
und lass es auf dem herd erhitzen
minute dann fast kocht nehmen die sie
vom herz und damit das gefühl und
weinstadt geht habe ich mir dazu einem
spritzbeutel den spritzbeutel habe ich
über einen plan so wenn ich beide hände
frei und stand kommt da die heiße
marmelade beziehungsweise das
pflaumenmus rein
dann verschließe ich die tüte groth am
besten mit einem knüppel und dann mit
vorne eine kleine spitze abgeschnitten
jetzt nehme ich mir einen keks und
spritzt da erstmal den konturen ton
und dann kommt auch noch die füllung
innen rein macht da nicht so viel damit
es nicht an den rändern noch ausgewählt
und da kommt jetzt der deckel ganz
leicht obendrauf
und wer möchte kann hier noch etwas
schlauer mose einführen
[Musik]
und so sehen dann die fertigen kekse aus
die fertigen plätzchen müsst ihr dann in
einer dose aufbewahren und sie schmecken
erst nach dem ersten oder zweiten tag
richtig gut nachdem sie etwas
durchgezogen
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken wünsche euch eine gute zeit
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]